what started as a fringe comic-book
convention for a small group of fans has
grown into the pop cultural event of the
year
influenced in every form of
entertainment and drawing in over
130,000 attendees so where did this
cultural phenomenon begin let's go back
to 1970 when three comic-book
professionals shell Dorf Ken Kruger and
Richard Al banded together to organize
Southern California's first comic book
convention this three-day event was
called San Diego's Golden State
comic-con and was held at the u.s. grant
Hotel the special guests included
science fiction writer Ray Bradbury and
famous artist Jack Kirby over 300
attendees packed into the hotel's
basement for that groundbreaking event
which featured a dealer's room programs
and panels film screenings and more it
was essentially the model for every
comic book convention to follow the
event officially became the San Diego
Comic Con in 1973 it was in 1974 when
the first masquerade debuted an annual
parade for cosplay and fan made costumes
with large prizes presented to the
winners in 1976 the publicity supervisor
of an unheard-of sci-fi film hosted a
panel showing slides on a projector to a
somewhat skeptical audience that film
was Star Wars and thus began the
practice of promoting films at Comic Con
in hopes of reaching fans like never
before
in 1979 comic Ellen moved to the
convention and Performing Arts Center
and stayed there until 1991 when the new
San Diego Convention Center opened
comic-con has called it home ever since
but the convention was still very
different from the one that we know
today as comic-book movies have become
increasingly important to Hollywood the
big box-office success of x-men in 2000
is generally considered the turning
point for the con click to watch this
awesome video we made about the history
of comic book movies Hollywood took
another look at this comic book
convention that had never previously
attracted much of their attention and
they found that they should promote
their comic related projects more
involvement in movies and television at
Comic Con led to more mainstream media
attention and a wider base of attendees
the attendance has increased almost 60%
in the last decade
movie studios know that their core fan
audience attends these conventions and
that they need to amuse and excite
then in order to spread good buzz about
a movie around 2004 the convention
center opened up Hall H to be used as a
giant 6500 seat auditorium for large
presentations by Hollywood studios today
fans are known to camp out for days to
get a seat in this legendary auditorium
to see a first sneak peek at their
favorite franchises remember when Zack
Snyder announced Batman vs Superman or
when Andrew Garfield took the mic in a
spider-man costume moments like this
keep people on the edge of their seats
each year since 2007 tickets for the
event have completely sold out and in
2011 tickets sold out in the first day
of the sale a trend that has continued
since the attendance in the Convention
Center has reached 130,000 people in
recent years and those fans love to
spend money the event pumps 180 million
dollars into the local economy of San
Diego today Comic Con occupies a giant
exhibit hall topping over 460 thousand
square feet featuring a massive
programming schedule of 600 separate
events spread over four days covering
comics and all aspects of the popular
arts but the Comic Con experience goes
beyond the convention center it now
extends to local hotels bars restaurants
Petco Park Stadium nerd HQ Walking Dead
zombie run Game of Thrones pedicabs
and so much more transforming the city
into a world right out of the pages of
fantasy and science fiction it's more
than just buying action figures of your
favorite Ninja Turtle it's a place where
fans can celebrate and interact with
their favorite media so what's the
future of comic-con San Diego approved
520 million dollars of expansion to the
convention center to make Comic Con even
bigger and better for fans with the
increasing popularity of the event and
comic book movies it's a fun time for
fans everywhere are you excited for
Comic Con what's your favorite part of
Comic Con let us know in the comments
below and get ready for whatever crazy
and awesome moments come this year stay
tuned to super comic fun time for more
original Comic Con videos to be in the
know about this extraordinary event